with terrifying speed an avalanche can
Rumble down a mountain slope burying
everything in his path under a lethal
blanket of snow
each year about 150 people in Europe and
North America die from avalanches large
ones can wipe out forests and erase our
mountain villages avalanches come in
many forms some called Slough consists
of sliding loose snow others called slab
avalanches occur when large sections of
the snowpack crack off and crash down
the slope as snow falls it builds up
layer upon layer with enough time the
layers will harden and bond to one
another but when layers formed weak
bonds any new snow falls on an unstable
foundation and waits for the right
trigger avalanches are caused by sudden
changes a heavy snowfall strong winds or
a rapid change in temperature the shape
and angle of the slope are important
factors slopes over 60 degrees are
usually too steep slopes under 25
degrees or too gentle the danger zone
comes between 30 and 45 degrees just
where people like to ski and sled 90% of
avalanche victims died because they or
someone with them accidentally trigger
an avalanche contrary to popular opinion
loud noises like yelling won't trigger
avalanche in most cases it's the sudden
weight of a skier or snowmobiling that
makes the surface unstable then the
Avalanche descends at speeds up to 80
miles an hour
as winter sports become more popular
avalanches pose more of a threat ski
patrols now monitor popular slopes to
prevent avalanches from ever happening
cannons fire explosives as slam into
snow bags to trigger small avalanches
before the build-up becomes a problem
[Music]
search-and-rescue teams practice
locating and digging out people trapped
underneath the snow but ultimately it's
up to every person to watch out when
they're on the slope so pay attention to
the weather look for warning signs learn
what to do in an emergency because
everything change in just a few seconds